on ne marie harmonie bonjour je n'arrive
pas à envoyer un clin d'oeil à quelqu'un
est-ce que c'est ma page qui est cassé
c'est ce que m'a pas gêné cas c'est que
jamais entendu parler de ça mais bon
vous utilisez votre compte ea harmonie
pour la première fois oui d'ailleurs je
regarde votre profil
on a un algorithme de recherche de
compatibilité à s'élaborer c'est ce qui
nous différencie des autres sociétés en
compte
oui c'est un plus en fait je vais
envoyer un clin d'oeil à une personne en
particulier
cheryl mais l'ofs elle travaille au même
étage que moi depuis un mois environ et
je n'ai entendu à la caf et dire qu'elle
est sur votre site
ah d'accord ça c'est une première mais
les dents vous avez laissé beaucoup de
choses là la rubrique vu ci fais ça par
exemple vous avez rémy oui je crois que
je les passais ah oui mais non il faut
m'aider un peu là il faut pas passer des
trucs mais je n'ai jamais fait de
voyages remarquables ou digne d'intérêt
mais vous vous avez pas fait des trucs
que remarquable c'est toujours là
attendez un instant
et vous
réparer cette percée j'ai entendu aboyer
j'ai cru sentir le gage
vous m'en voudrais trajet j'ai conçu une
prothèse pour chip cependant que je
déballais l'escalier une petite
patinoire jeudi que lui avec solistes
qui se sont réglables et support
ventrale me tenait jusqu'à 17 digne
d'intérêt
c'est que abc et man who is who dat
bravoure créativité les qualités de mon
eau minérale
walter est oui alors vous êtes là oui
vous êtes tombé dans les pommes
non j'ai juste une jeudi connu que tu as
d'accord ça vous arrive souvent